Well,
I mean,
I think that's always sort of the fun
part about the story about deal stories
is that they often have this almost
movie like quality to them where they're
meeting in secret hotel rooms and there
have project code words and you have
teams of people,
oftentimes hundreds of people who are
under this kind of a cone of silence and
you know,
how they make a deal happen or not.
Oftentimes there's not just two people
coming together in a friendly way.
There's multiple bidders.
Someone is the jilted lover who doesn't
get their,
uh,
it doesn't get the bride.
And so there really is a great story
here,
but you know,
you asked how do these deals really come
together?
I think in one way,
in every situation somebody is looking
for an opportunity.
Everyone in the deal world is an
opportunist,
so they're looking at the stock price.
They're looking at the relationship
between the CEO and the board.
They're looking at whether the CEO is
about to be ousted and maybe there's an
opportunity to come in then and there.
They're looking for weakness,
frankly,
oftentimes.
And,
you know,
all of that collectively is,
is,
is the great soap opera that makes my
job so much
fun.
You know,
what,
what's made this actually so interesting
is that the deal landscape,
if you will,
the players,
uh,
and the importance of the relative
importance of each player has changed
dramatically in the past,
say 12 or 18 months or 12 months ago.
The most important people on the planet
were these people called private equity,
which is sort of a misnomer for what
would otherwise,
or a polite way to describe Lbo is or,
or leveraged buyouts,
which is sort of a less polite word that
people didn't like in the eighties.
But you know,
whether it was Henry Kravis or Steve
Schwarzman from blackstone or the guys
at tpg or Carlyle in Washington,
these guys with the power players,
they were the hitters because they had
amassed all this money and we're
spending it at,
at outrigger outrageous songs at an
outrageous pace.
And you saw some very big blue chip
companies,
uh,
get taken out,
get bought in these massive buyouts.
Um,
you know,
now that we've had this credit crunch,
a,
they still have cash,
but they can't,
they can't add the steroids,
right?
They can't add the juice that makes
their formula work and therefore they're
sort of sidelined and now you're seeing
big corporations big what they call
strategic players come in and start
making deals.
They had sort of been cast aside because
they couldn't afford to pay the premiums
that private equity was paying.
And frankly,
it's unclear where the private equity
should've been paying those premiums to
begin with.
We'll see how those deals work out.
But you know,
now,
you know,
in the news there's rumors about Inbev,
the beer distributor in beer
manufacturer trying to buy budweiser,
for example,
a anheuser busch.
That is.
And so,
you know,
that's a big strategic deal,
uh,
that about a year ago probably wouldn't
have happened.
So you're seeing sort of major
corporations,
I think that had sort of been,
hadn't really been thinking about
acquisitions because they didn't know
how to compete against private equity.
Is,
is the new power player.
So it's no longer a cabal of 10 or five
guys from the private equity world who
are going to rule the world for the next
couple of years.
It's really the CEO's of big
corporations and the bankers and lawyers
behind the scenes that are making these
deals happen.
Hot Sector is always a dangerous
question because,
uh,
it,
you can never get the answer right.
Just when you think it's hard.
It's not,
um,
you know,
I think right now you're going to see
transactions in the financial,
what they call financial services banks.
Everybody needs rescue financing.
You saw this,
all the banks go through this period in
November,
December where they wrote down billions
upon tens of billions of dollars and
they needed more cash to keep up,
to stay afloat frankly.
And you saw them go,
what they say go to the desert.
They would,
they would go to the Middle East and
raise money.
I think you're going to see a lot more
of that over the next couple of weeks,
frankly.
And I think you're also going to see
banks that need to consolidate and
there's always been consolidation than
financial services area,
but I think you're gonna see more and
more of that.
Obviously bear stearns in trouble goes
in and is now owned by JP Morgan,
but you're going to see countrywide gets
bought by a bank of America.
These are deals that are not going to be
with the calls from strength to
strength.
These are,
these are,
these are truly going to be distressed
deals were some,
some strong players taking over
distressed player and is seeing as we
talked about being an opportunistic,
being an opportunist,
you know,
really trying to take advantage of a
situation.